the jogan experience and the more you
study the ancient past whether it's in
ancient Greece or a lot of my book
focuses on Paleo Christianity the more
you see this kind of ritual can I can I
show you some images of of
paleochristian ritual yeah okay cool do
it I love it I love talking to you okay
cool what do you got uh Jamie there
should be um a folder called
cersi cersi like the lady from Game of
Thrones like the lady from Game of
Thrones yeah and she's my
favorite then we you'll get to know her
a lot better A Great Character you'll
get to know her a lot better
Shame
Shame what am I looking for here this um
it's it's in in my uh my Google Drive oh
no no yeah I have the folder what do you
want me to pull up first few pictures
are just yeah just from the just from
the first one yeah we can start with
with we can go into the pictures I'm my
point I'm just my point it's just words
though it's that's fine okay we can we
can move forward from there so what I'm
going to show you are some images from a
hypium and I don't think we got around
to this last time but a hypium was this
underground chamber and it was the site
where most of the early Christian ritual
took place so if you if you think back
to paleo Christianity um between the
death of Christ and Constantine which is
300 years later give or take you know
Christianity was this illegal cult it
was this underground religion in some
cases literally so the only the only
places where you would celebrate the
Eucharist and the Proto Mass were in um
like small in private homes and and this
Agape meal and then sometimes you'd go
underground into these like necropolis
like the the these places of of the dead
and that for some reason was the place
where the mass was celebrated and so uh
as part of my research for the book I
went into some of these uh underground
Chambers to see what the earliest
Christians would have seen and some of
the evidence that was left behind in in
in terms of like frescos so there's no
Botanical chemical analysis of what was
happening happening in these places but
we do have images we have frescos and we
have the idea of what the early ritual
would have looked like and a couple
weeks ago I reached out to the Vatican
specifically uh to ask them if I could
show these images uh to you today and
they and they said yes all right thank
you
Vatican they're actually take back all
the I said about
you they're actually they're they're
great research Partners um the it's the
pontifical commission for sacred AR
iology so it's the archaeological team
that is responsible for the preservation
and conservation of all these ancient
sites and I think it's it's an aspect of
of early Christianity that like very few
people know about and so uh what was
happening underground um if you want to
go back to the first slide just just
quickly there was this Yale Professor
who sadly uh died um in recent years and
Ramsey McMullen and what he talks about
are these underground um these
underground chill outs they were called
vigilia the Latin word for them is
refrigerium where we get the word
refrigerator so they were like
underground chill outs where uh
certainly the Romans and it's believed
the earliest Christians would have gone
to celebrate um the Dead with uh with
sacramental wine with celebratory wine
they would have a wine ceremony in these
dank Chambers underground to like Usher
the dead into the Afterlife or bring
them bring them refreshment they were
called refrigera uh and so it's it's
kind of unclear when the refrigera a
pagan Roman ceremony became like a Proto
Eucharistic Christian Mass like the line
again the line is very blurred at this
period of time uh which I call the Pagan
continuity hypothesis this notion that
the the the the older wine drinking
consumption by the Romans the Greeks
before them somehow influenced at least
in some in some cases the earliest
celebrations of the mass and so I just
show this quickly to show um that you
know in these WI parties uh Ramsey has
this great line saying that this was not
just picnicking at the bottom there he
said this was religion so even though it
looks like a picnic it looks like they
were gathering over like kind of like
almost like a Mexican Day of the Dead
ceremony like they would meet by the
graveyard to uh to remember the dead and
the ancestors yeah there was there was
Wine and Food but this was this was
religion to the ancient Romans and I
think to to the romanized Christians who
followed them in the first first century
second century third Century um so the
next slide is um that that's just a
bunch more text from uh a Catholic
Encyclopedia by the way from 1907 if I'm
not mistaken and it talks about how the
celebration of the dead and this funeral
banquet you see right in the middle
there this notion that the funeral
banquet is really kind of at the core of
what the early Mass was even if you go
back to the Gospels it was you know
Jesus asking for the commemoration of
this event you know do this in memory of
me as you do this in memory of me
remember my life death and eventual
Resurrection this is this is sort of the
the prototype for for the mass and so
it's important to remember that the
funeral banquet was there to bind those
together who remained faithful to the
memory of Jesus after after his death
it's very similar to this Roman
refrigerium so I I give that all that as
background just to show you the first
couple images from the hypium so if you
uh skip to the next one or May so that's
what it looks like when you go
underground um there was it was
discovered in 1919 I think as as a Fiat
shop around the corner was trying to
expand into a garage they they came
across these uh these monuments wow
which which is not uncommon in Greece
and Italy and around the Mediteranean so
they found this this hypium which dates
to the 3 Century ad so we don't have
firm dates it could be anywhere from
like 220 to 250 ad so this is the time
period we're talking about um so the
these the it was these were tombs they
Rock Cut tombs in the hypium here if you
go to the next one uh one of the first
things I saw when I went into
the hypium was this which uh you know
it's it's a little strange because again
you're trying to figure out if this is a
Roman Pagan refrigerium or if this is a
Christian celebration of some sort of
Eucharist because again this site is
controlled by the Vatican the Vatican
has preserved this uh for uh uh for for
reasons um and you know it's been said
by the pontifical commission that these
are some of the most explicit and
concrete evidence for the origins of
Christianity so this is you know whether
this is purely Pagan or Christian is
sort of a a moment of of debate but now
if you just look at it what's odd is
that you see 12 people gathered around a
table and when you think of 12 people
gathered around a table you think of
something like the last supper and so
it's it's pretty clear that what's
important to this dinner is the Chalice
that that's being lifted by uh by the
servant there or maybe it's a priest of
some sort so it's clear that whatever is
happening wine is important to this
Gathering of 12 people the interesting
part is the woman who's appearing in the
back if you look closely um there's sort
of like the this Effigy Of A woman
descending exactly from the background
to the foreground it's thought that she
is Aurelia Prima and aelia was one of
the the the dead women to whom the
hypium was was dedicated and so what
they think that's her this is one one of
the vatican's interpretations is that
that's her emerging from the world of
the Dead to take place in this funeral
banquet and
ceremony so we're not really sure how do
they interpret that because she's not
seated at the table and because what
what they think this is is that whenever
especially because of of the place that
we're in which is underground that when
wine is being served um at a refrigerium
that the Romans would would habitually
do this in order to commune with the
dead not as a picnic but as religion as
Ramsey McMullen says so this is this was
their religion for for keeping alive
that relationship to the dead and
refreshing the Dead in the afterlife and
when you went there to celebrate them
they would appear oh and Ramsey has this
great line in his scholarship where he
says the dead themselves participated
which one of my favorite lines in his
research the dead themselves
participated so so that that's that's
Aurelia participating in a funeral
banquet that's happening underground
oh okay so if if we go to the next slide
so again unclear if that's um if that's
Christian or Pagan and and then uh you
see some of these images that's
interpreted as Jesus as the Good
Shepherd from The Gospel of John you see
the the goats down below so that's and
this is um that's either interpreted as
St Paul or platinus platinus was this
neoplatonic philosopher uh who lived in
around that time in the third Century um
and so it's unclear if that's St Paul or
platinus or maybe it's Paul using the
image of ptinus to call up the the the
imagery and again everything is very
ambiguous because Christianity is
illegal so you don't go you don't go
down there and paint very explicit
images of Jesus or the last supper or or
Christian elements because you could get
in trouble for that obviously so there's
a lot of ambiguity in these frescos uh
so if you move move past that this this
is the the most important one which is
kind of kind of mindboggling so this is
just to the right of that banquet scene
and it's called the homeric Fresco and
it's called the homeric Fresco because
it seems to to portray a very famous
scene from Homer's Odyssey uh and it's
it's when odius is stuck on the island
with Cersei the witch Cersei The
prototypical Witch of antiquity Cersei
he stuck on on on the island with her
and the three dudes you see there on the
bottom to the left have just been
transformed from pigs back into men it's
one of the most famous scenes in book 10
of the Odyssey where cersi uh delivers a
potion she concocts a potion and in
Greek it says that the verb that they
use her concoct the potion is Kio like
she just like the ancient potion at alus
this is one of the mythical um this is
one of the mythical precedence for what
would become the actual Kon that was
used in the Elan Mysteries and so she
she uses this this mythical Kon um in
which she um she casts these drugs it
says that she puts drugs into this
potion to transform the men into pigs
then back to men so it's a very I mean
like of all the 27,000 and Chang lines
of the Odyssey and The Iliad it's it's
it's a particularly strange image to
evoke from Homer because Cersei amongst
all the many things she's famous for is
for being a witch and and for having
this this profound knowledge of the
Botanical world and potions and things
that we might call psychedelics today
and so it's just it's it's it's a really
strange image to have there and um so
the Vatican produced this this monograph
uh over a decade ago where one of their
Scholars Alexia latini goes over this in
great great detail to to demonstrate why
exactly this is this is Cersei and up
above that's another image of Cersei
with all her animals on this magical
Island and what they found there exactly
was was cinear um and during the
conservation process they they were able
to identify the uh the Mercury sulfide
that had been used to paint this this
red image of of cabar around the house
which is a very telling detail because
there's a line just before this in the
Odyssey where it talks about the fiery
smoke coming out of cersei's cersei's
Palace so between the fiery smoke and
the cinear and um and the the web down
below the there there's a lot of
certainty that this is this is probably
Cersei um if you go to the next slide
what is can I ask you what are those
people laying down if you zoom in on
Cersei right here yeah up above what are
those people laying down supposed to
represent that's the the interpretation
from the the monograph is that that's
some sort of funeral beer so oh so those
are dead people they could be dead
people yeah which is also
strange what's that
Satan like Satan that we can't make
out so the the the loom was another
Telltale sign so there's the fiery smoke
at the palace and the loom is another
Telltale sign so this is if it were just
this you you would think okay maybe uh
maybe it's just Cersei and Al Loom but
if you go to the next slide there's
there a that and the next one yeah
there's there's a manuscript um at the v
in the in the in the Pope's Library uh
called the virgilius vaticanus you can
find this online in the virgilius
vaticanus manuscript which is from about
400 to 430 ad there's this picture of
Cersei and the loom which corresponds to
Cersei and the loom on the right so they
they know for sure you know with with
relative certainty at least uh that
there's there there's some image
continuity between Cersei and the Looms
and she tal she's talked about in the
ancient literature as as always being at
the loom uh so the confidence is rising
this this is and for folks who don't
know what a loom is it's how you create
cloth with
threads some people yeah yeah that's
true so with this for you're just
listening to this what she has is like
if you've ever seen people make cloth in
in a traditional way with a loom she's
got the the why did they depict her with
a loom why was she known as a he makes
cloth CU that that's what Homer said
that's what Homer says in his epic
poetry and that that's what Virgil also
says in his epic poetry so Homer writes
The Odyssey centuries later uh Virgil
writes the anid and that's sort of the
the mythical founding of of Rome the
main character anas and in both versions
there's a Cersei character so this
Cersei character survives for centuries
in the ancient world uh from from the
Greek to to the Latin uh and in in both
cases uh the the loom is mentioned and
also what's mentioned um in in these
passages are are the fact that that
Cersei uses potent herbs in the Latin
says potius edes so she's using potent
herbs and mixing up potions to transform
these men into pigs and vice versa so
like it's a very it's a very strange
it's a very strange idea to have a pagan
Witch uh in a fresco that's been
preserved in this paleo Christian
Monument uh combined with this this
refrigerium sort of Eucharistic cele
ation of the dead and then in the last
few images um what it depicts is a woman
being initiated into these into these
high
Mysteries so things you don't normally
associate with early
Christianity